[Musik]
[Applaus]
komm ich kaffee trinken sie über noch
70 millionen mal 70 meter wenn man muss
immer damit gesagt
andreas september dienstes eben in
münster werden übrig bleiben
noch mal so ein fall ist nicht möglich
so was hat die schweiz nicht mal meine
verhaftung gewartet nochmals jede schule
gast erwischte
damals ab und zur fürs theater über den
verein berichtet und bieten einmal an
der gerichtsverhandlung
und hat man die amazon hat eine also
immerhin polizist und politisch die hand
reicht eigentlich ostsee vom alter her
ähnliche frisur und so werden vermutlich
habe ich mich darüber aber aus liegt das
land politisch und der anderen wie du
bekommst du diese frau böhm sagt nein
und ich und meine schafe
ich will dass du weißt aber die sehr
gern und egal was passiert vergessen
dass im ok
[Musik]
so locken
natürlich nicht
wir sehen uns haben
[Musik]
danke dass ich ein normaler junger markt
sind disco besucht sich an iliad spielt
sich wenn jemand gegen gewalt also aber
mit der b 20 21 so eigentlich gut
kennengelernt
aber dieser lütz internet unbedingt
heilig sie ich hätte mir diese diese
liter sofort erkannt und entfernt
[Musik]
dazu muss ja nicht im spielsalon der
elias waren gut oder eine frage wo kann
ich nicht vergesse was würdest du machen
53 millionen
ich schaue ihn in augen und dann sage
ich ich bringe dich wo mit freunden
millionen
du hast mir ja jetzt auch für den film
wird das sich mit dem baustopp mit dem
elias al abdulla das sicher der post vor
der panik sie haben in der ganzen zeit
nie möglichkeit konkrete muss
verschiedenste drückt das hat sich
weiter gehe und jetzt habe ich auch da
will man also erst mit ihm kontakt
aufzunehmen
und er hat dann kunden micro erzählen
wie es wirklich ist was mich immer
geschrieben hat du jetzt gab es ja ich
bin wir sind
wir sind alle politischen gefangenen so
wir haben eine große urteil bekommen
ja aber er möchte ich lieber nicht
darüber reden zum telefon
okay aber besuch aus dem überhaupt
telefonieren ja eigentlich verboten
telefon aber sagen wir hier sind
musik 200 personen im gefängnis von
dieser musik 200 personen 900 haben an
der telefon
da machen wir jetzt vorwärts bewies ja
das ist ja dass ich sie 1996
ich war jung ich war stark
ich wollte spaß und so leben und ich war
geboren
ich arbeitete seit zwei jahren in
münster posten nie war so eine art
hilfsarbeiter
sie hatte nicht viele lohn ich komm ich
lasse mir nichts anmerken war immer
freundlich aber eigentlich war ich nicht
zufrieden mit meinem leben ich habe mich
bei der polizeischule in italien
geworden
aber da hat man mich nicht gewollt es
waren so viele bewerber
und die ich hatte probleme mit sprache
ich bin sieben jahre in die schweiz in
die schule gegangen dann sieben jahre in
italien und mit 14 ich komme wieder in
die schweiz
[Musik]
irgendwie
hatte ich alles falsch gemacht den
traumjob bekannten nicht
und ich hatte schule wegen dem unfall
ich musste sogar für den baum 500
franken bezahlen
denn ich ihn eingefangen
und da brauchte ich auch geld für ein
neues auto
sie musste auch über für die wallis
dass es war mein zweiter
eine karriere als alleine
[Musik]
wir finden zusätzlich zu meinem job bei
der post
zähneputzen morgens vor der arbeit eine
wurst
in syrien damals enorm viel qualm der
stadt ist das völlig anders
syrische strahlen die stadt
[Applaus]
neunzigerjahre senior taxi für den
offenen drogenszene sehr viel ich auch
in ordnung sie dort die drogenszene
und wenn du drauf los
also es hat in den neunziger jahren teil
endet wenn sie das mit einer intensität
immer wieder beruflich mit überhohen da
hat der der bruch straub irgendwo sehr
gutes bild passt
der besitzer von der otago badete gesagt
ich soll alles vorbereitet und mich dann
mit einem elias treffen
ich kannte diesen typen fordert nicht
aber dass er ein richtiger krimineller
ist
kraft ja mit mit geschäften links und
rechts vorfall damals war ich so mit
drogen gehandelt
die leute beschissenen damals noch von
mir auch die andere kriminelle wurde
da wurde ich teufel
[Musik]
aber keine ahnung ob du mich verarscht
richtig vor ort richtig froh ist mich
verarschen jetzt wir machen ja bist ok
schauen wir wenn ich dich vernaschen
du bist ne kiste wenn du mich verarschen
ich behindert ist du willst etwas machen
rang
[Musik]
und auch schon
respekt
alles gemacht
fotos von borsdorf schlüssel aus leipzig
gemacht von denen aus es ist
und genau an die position zum geld ist
okay was ich mir denke es gibt keine
waffe sicher diese auto bekommt geld
abholen kommt ohne polizei die
postbeamten haben keine waffe dieser
transport geht hin und her ohne
polizeischutz ohne waffen so sich
eigentlich ich habe gedacht dass ich
einen witz ihr habt der 4 minute für
minute
ok
diese schlüsse ruhig
[Musik]
sehr gut habe ich dann gemacht
jetzt bin ich dran mit sind es dort
weiter und das allerwichtigste
zerstöre diese fotos keine probleme
[Musik]
hey hey ich hab keine chance ich weiß
doch dass dann auch die spectro napoleon
korrigierte sie napoleon abgesagt das
ist im spox sie haben
[Musik]
dazu kommen risiko
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die zukunft
was du spinnst doch und bitte schauen
dass ich keine kraft die beste meine
relation mit christina war sehr gut
christina scheine
soll ich sagen eine sehr
verantwortungsvolle frau sie schaut für
haushaltsjahr arbeiten sie sich perfekt
ist der mensch der welt sondern man
nicht auf die wohnung alles ich schaue
dass ich möchte es ihm glauben bestehen
über dich gekleidet und christina
mussten die bezahl ich habe aus meinem
geld bezogen so es war eine kleine
paradies wurde nicht glücklich also das
heißt du als kalkar ja ja ich habe 100
100 10 tausend franken export in den
libanon
niemand fragt du hast du andrea wenn
jemand spricht von millionen dann
100.000 ich nicht so viel dass ich eine
chance kriegt musste diese nutzen
ich wusste eine solche chance kunden
oder einmal im leben
[Musik]
stimmt es dass ihr aber immer dem
betroffenen wird so wieder machen wie
eine büro wir reden schauen dass niemand
kommt stimmt aber die kumpels also wie
hast du überhaupt rekrutiert hat nun die
wäre
bist du zusammen in disco wieder in
sachen gemacht um gewonnen
wir werden viel zusammen bleibt bleibt
bleibt bis ich sage dass ich meine
zeichen wenn ich gebe eine zeichen ich
würde so machen wie werde ich machen
morgen noch keine scheiße
ich gebe dem moment da ich will dass
keine mach deine scheiße bohlens
[Musik]
du bist den sport
[Gelächter]
unsere fahrer sind jetzt in zusammen
disco gegangen ein paar mal bei mir
geschlafen
am ende waren ganz ruhig
dann habe ich z
so wurde auch sehr korrekt dass ich sie
lockt sie wurden ja ich eine gute freund
elias ich erwarte immer galt und autos
und discos restaurants ohne schaffe sap
ist sie aber was ich kurz gefunden in
elias elhardt herz co das ist sehr
stattlich wurde in einen mensch wenn er
und herzig kann nie ein freund von mir
sein vorstellen
im libanon groß umstadt geworden wenn
ich nur wüsste was auf und sondern unser
glücksbringer
ich bring dir dem aus ich habe gerade
erklärt
[Musik]
du bleibst sowieso gemacht
so dass ich ihnen hier gefahren rein das
ist sein körper und seele gut blasen
trank er bleibt
sie sind in der bauer immer wieder thema
firma hat sich also zweimal gestellt
dass jeder sind job kann hat inside hat
vorrangig alles schön mit komm ruft
kisten sind da was ich die rampe klinik
besteht darin ist super zu
aber wir waren keine waffen
ein raubüberfall engagement mit finger
machen also dieser paar minuten
wichtiger wie eine böse kriminellen sich
zeigen
waffen die waffen ich habe gesagt wir
nehmen keine waffen wir müssen etwas
nehmen das ausgesehen wie ein richtiger
gestohlen aber keine richtige bestellbar
und diese glauben angekauft jemand von
security war er war bewaffnet und ich
gerne vom vor was waffe die jungs gehen
sich loch auch die post ist genau so
etwas ist nicht so viel geschlafen ich
brauche dich holen okay
[Musik]
können wir das ding verschieben
vielleicht was worden waren morgen geht
es los
[Musik]
fr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
werden wir vom erster september am
morgen
ich war vorbereitet
ich war cool und ich danke mein job
macht zeit gut verstehen marcello guard
uns gebracht
sie haben ein auto vorbereitet hat
fürsprecher wie eine kette der autor
ausgesehen
perfekt geführt dass wir über das wir
kriegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gut ist
nicht perfekt geföhnter tisch genommen
ganz
wenn sie nicht gemacht
plötzlich
[Musik]
langsam verstanden was passiert ich
hatte angst
aber die haben wir dann waren schon
bereit haben sich organisiert
es gab für mich kein zurück mehr
da kommen sicher
und ich gebe die befehle wenn sie noch
gegen deine scheiße nicht los nach
sorgen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was hat damit gestorben
hasan war befreundet mit elias aber ich
hatte nicht viel was hab ich gesagt
was hat macht schon gesagt hat noch
nicht angerufen heute okay
hast du angst nein ich habe keine angst
gehabt
nein ich war sicher es gibt keine gewalt
einzige ist wenn polizei kommt müssen
wir machen hände hoch und sagen okay
gegeben
[Musik]
was kommt
wir hätten schon seit alberts oder eine
stunde
aber die kings lettern transporters
keine ahnung ob bei einer verspätung
gehabt hat
[Musik]
ich habe es kaum ausgehalten
ausgerechnet heute war der zeitplan
anders
mit ihnen kommt mit ihnen weiß worden
ok
[Musik]
was glaubst du wie sieht man in zukunft
aus
ich sehr viel geld was noch viel frau
[Musik]
und 2
keine chance
[Musik]
die hannoveraner auf quartett vom
insider und und hat sich ein dessert
norm halte zog davon
küsse unverfrorenheit die jungen leute
hören hat es ist noch cool
[Musik]
ich musste ja arbeiten so tun als wäre
alles normal
und der wusste jetzt passiert das
gleiche übel fahren und ich bin schuld
[Musik]
das codewort kann wenn er seit 5 uhr
das heißt für uns 50 millionen wenn er
seit 35
ich komme um 35 einen kaffee trinken das
heißt 55 millionen 660 millionen ihr
später desto besser über ums leben
herrscht könig kaffeetrinken 78
[Musik]
70 kommt widerruf automatisch kommt
alles wieder im kopf und in guernsey
marine
ich musste natürlich nicht mit
fingerabdruck sonder so mit dem ta
ja meine freunde telekom
im moment steht musik unseres chefs
ablade wir sind gerade wieder mehr
weiter trinken einen kaffee
also sicherheitskonzept ist sie ein
geldumschlag felix ist der schleuse
gemacht und auf der anderen seite vom
hof ist ausgangs- und david ballaballa
und dann ist eine praktische schützt sie
und dafür sorgen dass niemand anders die
dem ruf ich als dir wo mit dem geld und
fragen was ist los sind fahrt durch und
rückte mit
[Musik]
ja ja ja der schleuse ein klarer fehler
gemacht die unter keinen umständen auf
der luft würden gut kumpels und wenn
peter scheifler maxi und wenn der
telekom noch unter zeit dort auch nicht
so blöd und aus mähne
denn auch eine seite für die asiatische
der fonds und lauten er merkt dass das
viel zu teuer und seele ist dass man das
in einem sicherheitsbereich haifa keinen
umständen der aufnahme
es geht los
elias
elias hallo
andrea hallo
[Musik]
kommission
keine minute
elias hallo was ist verkehrt und hält am
edelhof gräfin von pocci wir sind
hineingefahren haben auto produziert
und ich bin ausgestiegen als er stellt
und es war nur einfach ich bin
ausgestiegen und ich bin nicht einmal
zwei meter gelaufen
und schon kommen die leute mit dem geld
raus abgemacht bekommen und das geld ist
rausgekommen und ja und dann habe ich
mit dem finger die zeichen gemacht für
die kollegen das hier rauskommen aus dem
auto aber zu denen es im moment ich
würde wie hassan anfängt gegen die türe
zu schrauben einfach eine bu und dann
ist für die schau und wie eine wie eine
wahnsinnige unterricht ein komplize
gewesen hätte ich garantiert sich angst
gehabt von vom seine aktion
nein niemand hat eine maske getragen
nein weil wir haben gewusst dass wenn
sie sind schockiert dann sie vergessen
sowieso die die gesichter noch benutzen
so wir sind ohne masken lange bangen
letztes jahr als prediger cotton gemacht
und einmal bronze oder damit zwar nicht
ob sie einmal was ich was ist los was
ist passiert und dann hat er denn eine
total auf ein treues fotos und wieder
war eine mit pistole quasi jahre alte
mann sitzt wegen der behinderten deshalb
vorhersagen hat doch der haus und hatte
eine waffe die ich sehe wie die
botschaft stellte sind der fußgänger
dass das alles recht die wir auch fixies
sind zusätze sich nicht so verhalten sie
natürlich auch immer so wird das bild
das man sich gar kein bewaffnet die
gegner mittel werde überhaupt gehört
wiederum sagte bewegen auch firmenerben
80 oder 90 aus plastik sie wäre dann
hätten wir das unter anderem ische
kalaschnikow der pixi man weiß was die
mitte der sonne ausgerichtet werden also
das ist kein akt kalaschnikow es wurde
eine
spielzeug kann sich sicher dass avatar
ausruf kriegt oder die hitze geworfen
oder mit 18 habe die waffen sind sie für
mich sind die 80
sie sind sicher nicht mit
spielzeugwaffen ihr können
ich weiß alle leute denken es ist eine
richtig aber keine richtige sie meine
woche war auch nicht richtig alle wurden
die kisten waren ruf rampe
zwei kisten aufgeladen
die schwerste habe ich rufen bei
gelassener nicht probiert und zu schwer
und eine tanz hinter nur um unser team
sie hat dann aber feststellen wir sie
das ihren vier perino spitzley ist für
alle schichten und hängt ein
tatsächliches zwei fichten zurück glaube
mir werden wir zeit gärtig rt
irgendjemanden dort gelassen und zu fuß
die zwei gestern aufgeladen wir haben
keine zeit
polizist hat die handballer von debeka
und ihr herrn kubicki
wir haben gedacht wir müssen die hände
binden von der für die postangestellte
aber es ist so einfach gegangen alles
wir haben gar nicht gebraucht die letzte
momente wo wirklich sind ab sekunde
dort wo elias mit seinem schluss diese
tür aufmachen ist in diesem moment alle
tanks tor von paradies ist ich wurde auf
gemacht
sie sind ein großer gefahr innerhalb von
weniger als vier minuten und das ist sie
die polizei prüft wirklichkeitsnahe will
bis der erste ist 110 jahre geleitet hat
ist leider viel zeit vergangen
also ich bin eigentlich nach einer wohl
geholfen wurde dass ich allein trug der
chor die generika und zweitens ist
er habe sie von fans der an meinem
arbeitsplatz beobachten können und darf
so getan als würde ich nichts gemerkt
sind los
[Musik]
das mache dir
da passiert dann überfahren
ich habe gesagt das kann nicht sein
[Musik]
wir haben so herumgeschrien werden
überfallen dem korps genommen vor
[Musik]
was ist los
alles gut alles gut
[Musik]
und wer hat da gericht die photonen
verlor ich habe gehabt mir dass ich habe
ihnen eine schwarze mappe mit mir
getragen
ich weiß nicht wo ich sich aber verloren
ob er beim aussteigen aus dem auto der
rausspringen ich habe keine ahnung ich
drehe mich ich sehe außer mit
kalaschnikow die man noch identisch
sichtbare denkst du mission leben
da gibt es kein krieg ist vorbei bitte
macht diese machen diese kalaschnikow
weg
[Musik]
schnell
groß
fühlst du dich wie ich meine das machen
was du willst goldgas frau haben
auskaufen altersstil das ist schmuck und
in diesem moment in diesem moment ich
habe radio nachrichten gehört wie die
haben schon berichtet über drüber v wir
haben gehört die sirenen der
polizeiautos wird und pastis großräumig
abgesperrt
ich einen anruf über umsatz zentrale
bewaffneter raubüberfall ganze große
geschichte oft münsterbusch berufsgruppe
an ereignissen tatort und haben ihrem
alles bild verschafft sehr schnell
heimat ist das 70 millionen parks ist in
würfel dass sie tatsächlich metern
heimat der spitze zählen die erste
handlung sich sie das sich mit fragen
der mitglied kurz besprochen was ist
genau abgelaufen hat es irgendwelche
videoanlage bezeichnet wurde
das hat den durch die innenstadt müsse
ärztlich behandeln wo sonst kann weil
die trainer sagte sogar
er muss sehr schnell gefahren das ich
weiß noch nicht ob ich zu schnell fahren
so ein spiel vor der polizei ja noch
ungefähr fünf minuten wir wurden schon
in garage
[Musik]
hast du noch als zweite waffe kommen ja
ja ich habe eine zweite stunde dabei
gehabt die unklar aber diese woche nicht
wieder für den posten aber ich glaube
jetzt weißt du wir sind also spiel gehen
wir sind viele leute und jemanden will
vielleicht das kind alleine
[Musik]
da kann es für dich also ist mit
rassismus hat jemand von euch hat der
woche gesagt nein
[Musik]
aus dem osten habe ich gesagt ich will
sehen dass keine waffen ausziehen hier
ist die kleine nehmen sie gerade hier
noch unsicher und begleitet wird
außerdem habe ich gesagt das gibt dir
sagen wir so ich wäre bereit gewesen zu
schießen in die fuß- oder so andrea wenn
sie sich vor so viel geld so viel geld
die menschen durch vielleicht jemand
plötzlich alles alleine das ist so dass
ich wirklich schon die macher das ist
und deshalb ich wollte auch nicht in
dover morgen
ich hatte angst dass vielleicht dort ein
paar leute auf uns warten oder so ich
hatte wirklich angst dass immer noch
eine chance
unten verschlossen nehmen sie gleich gut
aber also das muss man erklären will
kommt es dass du mir einen vertrag hat
ich schaue ich bin mit 17 jahren ich
habe meine familie verlassen
ich bin europa nur mit einem rucksack so
ich habe niemand aber nichts ich muss
alles selber entscheiden und diese zeit
meine vorteile schon arbeit
ich habe dafür schwester meinen bruder
bloß motors vater leben auch noch solch
muss geld finden schicken damit auch
zehn personen leben können sind auch
dort von niemand bekommt und wenn so ist
einfach dass dann vielleicht kommt oft
die falsche straße wenn vielleicht tut
sich da nicht einfach zum geldverdienen
mit drogen was du machen machen wir
machen sich jetzt auf den enormen sich
die klasse mit deiner muss man
machen
[Musik]
ich habe den moment aber die geldbeträge
ok kommen
außerdem kommt zunehmend konsumieren 50
millionen sehr viel geld da schon betrag
war für kreisbaudirektor verstorben
vorstellbare ist als bisher was auch
nicht drin kommen jetzt nicht abfahren
2 denn die nächste frage ist sie meine
mutter aus den ca und für mich ist der
entscheid von clark sie sei von anfang
an sehr wichtig betrag wenn dimension
einmal klar ist den kunden auf die
details und 40 sich gefühlt ich bin
jetzt der könig und ich schaue dann an
und ich dann
sie werden müssen alle erwischt
sie sind zum großen teil sehr gut
vorbereitet sie bis zu dem moment aus in
ihrem unterschlupf sie sind eigentlich
einfach das riesige gehälter
jeder hat einen riesigen teile pro ich
damit mindestens vier millionen ab es
ist noch nicht fertig und wenn irgendwo
falsch gemacht haben bald polizei
ich würde es für das bild
max
wir schauen dass das auto noch ein
verschwinden also du hast die leoni ag -
die sag familie oder war so verteilt
dass die konflikte das heißt du hast nur
sieben millionen für disco
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und das stimmt nicht und ich habe meine
freunde angerufen
sie sagt was ist los ich sage kommen
nicht fragen welche reisekoffer mit dann
sich gekommen
wir haben diese koffer mit geld gefüllt
und dann essen wir haben gemacht in die
diese baby tasche genommen
die tasche gesteckt oder in ordnung und
ich hier wieder eingeschlafen der beben-
und so wir sind gefahren und hat das
baby hat geschlafen auf millionen im
alter von einem monat
du hast sehr gut er ist millionen
wir sind da wir sind nicht über nur
aufgefordert und autobahnpolizei und ich
denke auch mal laut polizei aber zum
glück sie haben uns nicht aufgehalten
und so ich habe die köpfe in meine
wohnung getragen
die sind trucks sind immer sehr sehr
schwer
motivation ist groß so ich habe ich bin
die treppe rauf wie eine feder gemacht
denn ich habe eine mitwisserin gerufen
sofort ich habe gesagt los da sind 14
metern firma cello 2 mit uns und für
dich bin ich geblieben mit 21 millionen
so dass ich mein geld ich bin der boss
ich habe das organisieren ich habe die
leute bezahlt punkt
[Musik]
über 53 millionen franken beute bei
einem überfall auf die historische
formen der post gewaltige medien öfter
mal fünfe vor der zürcher fraumünster
post im in und ausland des 10 trassen am
größten vor streller zum großeinkauf für
hollywood der tatort aber liegt in
zürich im bisher größten postraub der
schweiz entwendeten dreiste diebe in
über 53 millionen franken
die täter verschwanden spurlos
vd sind malaysia ferien und wir sind
morgen um sechs noten landet und den ist
ganz typisch cousine von der frau
und all dies die erste reaktion ist es
passiert
35 millionen franken ganz einfach abzüge
und das alles wieder wurst so einfach
gerade dritten schlag in marke dass das
ist ziemlich nah sagt wittmann
ich habe dort einen trost zu verachten
sind die bereiche führt bauer wenig mit
der er kann ja auch sein kann es
wahrscheinlich wenn überhaupt nur als
jux habe ihn gerührt und machen dann
versteuert der polizei
dann haben wir natürlich den überfall
schienen minuziös geplant die täter
mussten nicht nur das sicherheitssystem
sondern auch den zeitpunkt des
geldtransporters gekannt haben man hat
soviel sicherheitsvorkehrungen spielend
überwunden
es ist einfach derart gut zu wissen dass
es für mich sehr schnell praktisch nie
in zeitz nicht den heimen einer der
insider messen ermittler verdacht sofort
was uns passieren als dass der rooftop
muster involviert sie verknallt
und dann hat mit nudeln und hatten mit
mit einem polizeiauto angeschrieben noch
mit obama zusammen
die polizeiwache und dann ist irgendein
zurück
das büro hat
am nächsten tag am arbeitsplatz haben
zwei zivile polizisten abgeholt
ich wusste jetzt kommt das für das
machen sie medial ähnlich waren deshalb
ganz ruhe geben mit gegangen
wir müssen sie befragen kommen sie bitte
mit so freundlich haben sie mit mir
gesprochen
mit einer rotte fordert haben sie mich
zur ablage gebracht wie lange arbeiten
sich für die post seit juli 19 590 und
wo haben sie bei der ptt eingefunden
direkt dabei vom ministerposten 77
jedoch martin tagesablauf am tag des
überfalls
eine normale tage so musste er zähle
jede einzelheit die am tag des überfalls
aufgefallen ist
ob sie jemanden seltsam benommen habe
umso weiter lernen behindert die hebel
der täter vermutlich sagte er ich gesagt
das hat das wenn man über trauer wenn
jedem potenzieller gegen strich der
heute die mannschaft ja ich weiß dass da
sie ihre gemachten oder da bitte ich sie
aber eher durch dankt er wird
verdächtigt werden
gegen ihr weg mich bezahlen
wo waren sie und was sie im hof ich
verachte dani musste eine zeichnung von
ihnen auch für machen
da habe ich extra und schrift verstehen
die rampe gezeichnete die garage immer
damit seien falsch damit das einkaufen
hier also im zweiten stock wo wir abends
machte brav alles was sie wollten und
dazu immer erklärt aber damit erhält die
zeichnung für die ahnen der lernte ich
ja gemacht dafür dass also musste diese
doch anders aussehen
klar
ich habe gedacht was ist los sie haben
ja klar ich bin ich sofort gedacht er
muss elf also schon ein bisschen schnell
treppe runter kommen sie etwas mit dem
überfall zu tun
nein gar nichts gut danke danke
pro farbe herstellen teil vor dem
völligen freiheit also bis der post
passiert ich will ja ok person der
schattenseite die haben uns blöd sie und
den 350 millionen schenkel
schnebel verletzt worden
für die im ausland tätig sie sich an
umgegangen ist und ihr mann umgebracht
wurde und in dem quasi tom hicks idee
gestanden hatte und einzelne könnten
verhindern oder für mich sehen sie hier
in irgendeiner form hielt xi sondern sie
sind kriminelle wo ein coup gelungen ist
das sind wirklich geschockt
hallo hallo hallo du deine idee kommen
dass du mit deiner eine 20 millionen
macht ja meine idee war zwar schon
irgendwo nach brasilien zu gehen oder so
copacabana und dann ich wollte nach
nach libanon ein geschäft aufmachen oder
sogar mehr
aber das leider nicht so passiert
damit liege im busch denn für sie der
bruno kreisky steg an der wahl morgen
von jahrhundert knapp 2 eine politik die
berühmt espresso serviert hat somit
kaffee serviert und man ist ein christ
ist er zwar ruhig schon ich sage ja vor
dem haut fahren ist ein quietschen regel
meist sofort schaltet wo der züge das
denn der polizei für zelte und ein wir
sind sofort ihr kaffeetasse video
sammeln oder und tatsächlich heitz
fingerabdrücke
was glaubst du
wie sieht man in zukunft aus glaubt vom
haupttäter damit gegen rückraum ist als
es aufgrund dessen haben wir in
absolution angesetzt
[Musik]
wir sind in die wohnung von einer
freundin gefahren von mir und sie hat
mit der braut nichts zu tun als sich
eine anständige frau
wir haben das geht bei ihr in den
schrank gemacht 18 millionen
wir haben gedacht jemand kommt auf die
idee dass das kritisch bei ihr handy
telefon kontrolle gemacht nennt umfeld
abklärungen gemacht wer mit wem verband
lädt sich mit freundinnen ermittelt man
hat wonach der mit mikrofon am richtigen
ort installiert oder wann zehn namen
auto und hängt eine anfangen mit loser
und halten herr festgestellt dass der
reis plant gesundheit oder geführt
worden ist zum beispiel vom chef mit
seiner entourage nach mailand direkt
hotel milano haben dort eine suite
genommen haben wir den dom besucht
ich habe noch ein bisschen frisches geld
gewechselt
[Musik]
ja ich habe gewartet dass die freundin
kommt mit der freund und dass sie mit
dem geld kommen
mit 18 millionen das war der plan
da steht in post räubern die welt offen
mit all ihren verlockungen doch mit
vollen händen einfach so ausgeben würden
da die posträuber nicht auffallen
das ist sicher so dass es jetzt eine
extreme stresssituation ich will jetzt
im prinzip schwieriger wird es genau
dass die machen wir das machen
entscheidet letztendlich ist darüber
treffen was sie verwischt oder nicht
[Musik]
innerhalb von der stadt zürich die
stadtpolizei unheimlich gut vernetzt sie
und sich sehr schnell sind sache ist
zugänglich gemacht wurde wonach alles
viel länger kennt meint haug sehr
schnell visus der bevölkerung büro und
hippies überholtes die szenen im witt
ich diesen rock bar in seebach das sind
erste lied vor wird aber von der
haupttäter ist das netz ein beispiel sei
zufall war ich 50 100 meter und ich
konnte alles was was polizei macht bin
ich weg das war eine schwierige seite
nach dem überfall
sie müssen sich vorstellen vor allem
wenn man so angst vor allem wusste ich
nicht was mit meinem anteil passiert ist
ob mein vertrauensmann das geld wirklich
bekommen hatte ich konnte das ja noch
nicht kontrollieren
ich konnte mit niemand kontakt aufnehmen
wir haben beweise dafür dass sie an der
vorbereitung des raubüberfalls vom
ersten september 19 97 aktiv
teilgenommen
wir wissen dass sie an ihrem arbeitsort
fotoaufnahmen gemacht haben dann wäre
das das müssten sie doch eigentlich
wissen
b
am 2
ford sync gemacht habe diese fotos für
meine kollegen mir machen für welche
kollegen haben sie diese fotos gemacht
habe so garten wie die postkarten
gemacht und meine familie in italien
gesagt ich weiß dass sie auch im august
also unmittelbar vor dem überfall fotos
gemacht haben das stimmt nicht
aber wir haben beweist das
es kann sein ja bay
viele fordern das ist wie eine art wie
für mich aber was hat das mit dem
befahrene zu tun
ich würde sie noch mal auf die wahrheit
zu sorgen
in welcher form sie am überfall
beteiligt war sie können mich die ganze
nacht befragen
wir haben nichts damit zu tun wen haben
sie die fotos gegeben
niemanden ich mache nicht so etwas ich
möchte selber polizist wird
eine karriere als polizist können sie
bei ihrem neuen werk ist haben sie noch
etwas hinzuzufügen
[Musik]
neben der software auch der film re nie
so ganz sich sie ist ja dann hat man
natürlich auch in observiert und bürger
mit wem hat kontakten woche mit zusammen
wenn irgendeine mal heimersheimer grad
aus der tatverdacht sich derart für dich
derzeit gegen ihn im ganzen wichtiger
punkt einmal gewonnen ein
polizeioffizier gegenseite slogan hier
foto ap photo ich es mal ganz auto und
im hintergrund nur bei mir jetzt
aufnahmen von dem busche und zurück
kommt und das auto untersuchen dann
können wir irgendwann zum zeitpunkt
wurde fertig nacht wurden schon mit
apollo sein
und da ist natürlich die personen oder
sting psychisch sehr naheliegend dass
das muss drin sein
[Musik]
haben sie aufnahmen im innenhof
fraumünster post gemacht von den
sicherheitseinrichtungen
ich möchte zuerst beweismittel sehen
bevor ich antwort
[Musik]
erkennen sie die person mit einer kamera
im innenhof der fraumünster post
aufnahmen macht
[Musik]
ich erkenne mich selbst auf dieser front
doch außer
[Musik]
die in diesem moment wusste ich dass ich
keine chance im rat nicht nur gegen die
fotos ich hatte ja auch keine ahnung was
mit der anderen passiert ist ich wusste
auch nicht ob sie mich verraten gehört
an
[Musik]
haben sie diese information und der
täterschaft zukommen lassen
ja
das sind idioten
sie meinen die leute für die sie die
fotos gemacht haben ja haben sie selbst
die fotos der täterschaft zur verfügung
gestellt
gern können sie mir eine schriftliche
bestätigung nehmen dass wenn ich rede
ich nicht zehn oder zwanzig jahre hinter
gittern bleiben muss
[Musik]
die stadt gerichtet ich sie was
nacheinander
jetzt muss das konzept denn von mailand
ums sind ihre freundin telefoniert und
die freundin
ich denke frei geworden bist du im haus
innen oder bist du doch tatsächlich
beginne und der christlich gekommen mit
ihrem freund aber sie sich gekommen ohne
geld hat gesagt weißt du ja sich zu
gefährlich vielleicht es kommt eine
kontrolle oder so ich habe geld nicht
mehr gesehen
99 99 prozent womit vieles geld zu tun
hat wird sich verändern
das heißt wenn du hütchen vertrauen
nachdem er kontakt hat mit vieles geld
kriegen immer vertrauen auf 99 99
prozent die fracht um eine nachmittag
wir wollen das war dass ich vergesse
diesem moment ich wieder dass ich das
wort wie ein actionfilm wir sind raus
gekommen und dadurch die polizei
carabinieri alle 1 meter 80 1 meter 90
groß
überall stehen alfa romeo und ich glaube
und das ist alles sehr schnell gegangen
und ich habe nur noch ja plötzlich
wurden diese auf
die beiden jungen 21 knapp 21 die sind
mit den anderen spanien abgaben und
unter http
das ist de in marbella auf polizei gerne
und hat erzählt dass sich der baum mit
zwei jungen romy dominanter und hilfe
hsh 46 so fand das flotte leben in
spanien mit köpfchen prostituierten
rasch ein ungemütliches ende der
posträuber zoran v war mit 1,3 millionen
franken und schmuck in einer
straßenkontrolle hängen geblieben
ebenfalls ein rasches ende nahmen die
spanien träume von dtm mit seinem anteil
von 4 millionen franken kaufte er eine
acht zimmer villa samt umschwung
wo denn die erste klarheit ein
afrikanisches wenigsten stars musik
sorgt das verbrechen weiter
dank tipps von insidern konnte die
polizei die lange flucht von hassan
beenden
er wurde in berlin verhaftet damit sind
nun fünf der sechs täter gefasst
nach einer dann sind alle posträuber von
zürich gefasst
bei diesem einen handelt es sich um den
24 jährigen italiener domenico silano
forum bin ich nach venezuela geflogen
nach einer woche wo nicht die situation
in venezuela gesehen aber was habe ich
gesehen zuviel kriminalität
ich habe mich entschieden meine e-mail
ich kenne mich kein mensch mit seit ich
vermisse meine freundin als italiener
natürlich ist familie wichtig ist das
umfeld wichtig mit dem mit dem lied ohne
sexismus vermelden und und das hat alles
so bitz dazu geführt dass man immer
genau wüssten wundern sich ungefähr
aufhalten ich wusste schon wenn meine
freundin kommt zu mir ich meine flucht
beendet
ich will dass du weißt
habe die sehr gern und egal was passiert
vergesse das okay sie war eine woche bei
mir ein monat später die splitter und
sie sagte zu mir ich war bei
polizeiposten und dann frage ich wie
lange bis der text vier stunden
ok alles möchte ich keine sorge
meine freundin absolut keine
verräterischen nicht verlange von einem
normalen frau dass sie dass sie nicht
mit der polizei kooperiert und dennis
systematisch vortag seine arbeit weiter
mit der örtlichen polizei
man hat da man einerseits straße um
straße block komplett noch in fragt die
moschee besuchen die personen die eben
noch so
und irgendeiner unteren ecke er ist
sofort abtreten muss sie als umstellt
das ist meine größte tische bewaffneter
der not
[Musik]
ich konnte lesen auf einen artikel das
eingesetzt wurden 500 polizist oder 200
paar hundert sowieso meine wohnung also
rund meine wohnung waren nur polizisten
also ich konnte nicht abbauen und dann
verkauft
sind jetzt alle mutmaßlicher posträuber
verhaftet um das geniale zur post
beteiligt
ich setze mich jede persönliche
zufriedenheit und jetzt sagen sie mir
dann müssen sie ich bin sehr zufrieden
[Musik]
strafmildernde sieht das beim raum
unglaublich waffen im spiel sind dass
niemand verletzt wurde nicht dass da
nicht alles kochen die bahn die
zugeschlagen hat die risikoaktiva 350
millionen hätte geldstrafe wieder
verschärft
natürlich wünscht man sich als
staatsanwalt immer das lotus im
verfahren zum erlebnis strafverfolgung
bis lernen azubis mitnehmen und ihre
zukunft auf ehrlicher arbeit aufbauen
und und nehme kriminell sind das wünsche
ich eigentlich jedem beschuldigte vor
kriminalität
warum bist du denn wieder verhaftet
worden
ich bin weder budapest nach moskau
geflogen und am flughafen sie haben das
ist sie wegen 1983 wurde damals 17 jahre
alt lebt im libanon gemacht ich war das
ist der grund für glauben ich habe
millionen
[Musik]
rorstedt defizit geschrieben bis kurz
vor dem überfall sehr stark sie ein
minimaler gewinn gemacht hat im
sächsischen ski und 23 25 mio
also mein geld ist gefunden wurden 18
millionen mitgenommen diese hat die
polizei weggenommen
750.000 nicht aber gegeben eine andere
mitwisser
[Musik]
4 millionen und von dieser vier
millionen fass millionen wurde
verbraucht während der flucht
das lässt sich leider verschwunden
wahrscheinlich ja nicht falsch ende das
geld an getraut capriccioso ich würde
meinen arbeiten dass ich um sicht dass
die täter geld nicht viel gesehen muss
dem motto sexy sind die helfer und
helfershelfer die hunters gehälter kino
abgeschöpft verspekuliert oder was auch
immer das geld im finanzkreislauf
flossen also da hat es relativ schnell
nach einer party horwitz irgendwo im
tresor oder
[Musik]
da gibt es mehrere ziemlich gut ich kann
mich
wir sprechen jetzt klagen heute schaffe
ich es war man in deutschland ist jeder
ist willkommen
doch nicht schaffen einfach anständig
sein wo nicht geschafft
ich bereue gar nichts gar nichts
ich bereue gar nichts an im laufe der
arbeit von einer recherche deiner
interviews vor allem was ich mit meiner
räuber und daher mit der polizei
kurzerhand nicht hose gefunden warum der
polizist oder räuberischer ich denke
einfach von einer buch drüber sind das
alles junge männer wo als schienen oder
als jugendliche in hartz iv wird früher
wie viel co2 ausstoßen dass die sind
auch die reform wo endlich erlaubt
die jugend also mindestens thema nicht
kleiner mit der nicht punkten
und das ist sicher keine entschuldigung
für das was sie gemacht hat aber
vielleicht ist das stück erklärt bist du
denn jetzt
und die hälfte von meinem leben ich habe
in hinter gittern verbracht meine so
nicht in der schweiz
ich habe alles falsch gemacht
[Musik]